suter déjà vautibault dépêche toi p mais
je vais regarder au bureau comme chaque
matin papa bout qui est très pressé mais
petit bouc n'aime pas se dépêcher une
situation souvent bien connu des parents
et c'est justement l'objectif de ce
spectacle parler des relations
familiales au quotidien ce sont toujours
des problématiques autour de la
tendresse d'un quotidien qui est plein
de tendresse
il ya beaucoup de clins d'oeil pour les
parents il ya beaucoup de clins d'oeil
pour les frères et soeurs bon tout le
monde s'y retrouve
et puis ces problématiques de
confrontation de tendresse et on les a
toute notre vie à différents niveaux
dont le petit monde des mille la
compagnie coup de balai s'est inspiré de
trois histoires de l'auteur emile jadoul
de la petite fille qui prête son écharpe
à la maman un peu débordé à l'heure du
coucher
la lumière j'ai peur du noir le pipi les
enfants perçoivent exactement toutes les
subtilités psychologique des personnages
en fonction du jeu corporel et c'est
extraordinaire de voir comment il capte
ce qui se joue dans la relation d'une
manière fine et juste
le spectacle fera escale à la verrière
samedi 25 mars et pour les enfants
la prochaine fois que papa book dit
qu'ils comptent jusqu'à 3 il accompagne
les à trouver une réponse
mais si tu veux je pourrais apprendre
comme ça on serait moins pressés matin
[Musique]